the average German coal power station
emits around six million tons of co2 per
year that's about the same amount as
produced by a city like Frankfurt
everyone agrees that emission levels
need to be reduced after all fossil
fuels will still be used in the future
to produce electricity can Co to be
stored
experts have developed a process that
basically turns power station chimneys
upside down the environmentally harmful
gas doesn't escape into the air instead
it's pumped deep below the earth's
surface this procedure is called CCS or
carbon capture and storage this is how
it works co2 is separated from the other
gases emitted by power stations
liquefied and prepared for
transportation afterwards it passes
through a number of layers of rocks and
earth in pipelines and is stored in
cavities deep below the surface
the process has been the cause of much
heated debate for years those in favor
argue that we need coal power stations
to meet global energy demands and say
CCS helps produce energy in a more
environmentally friendly way especially
in countries like China with generous
coal reserves that are building large
numbers of power stations
environmentalists however say storing
co2 underground involves risks they
argue that the reservoirs in which co2
is stored underground could leak and
nobody knows for sure how the gas will
react under the Earth's surface
opponents fear that soil and groundwater
could be contaminated
here in Germany following loud protests
by local residents pilot projects have
been discontinued for the time being